Und was du jetzt gelernt hast,
wenden wir auch gleich mal an.
Wir werden eine erste technische Zeichnung mit Adobe
Illustrator erstellen.
Du kennst ja jetzt schon einige Grundfunktionen.
Zunächst wollen wir unsere Arbeit übersichtlich machen und
daher das Blatt etwas formatieren.
Unsere erste Ebene wird also als Formatgrundlage dienen.
Um mich zurecht zu finden,
möchte ich meinen Ebenen dann auch Namen geben und deswegen
gehe ich jetzt hier auf Ebene 1, klicke da drauf und kann
diesen Namen löschen und dann diese Ebene umbenennen und ich
nenne sie jetzt einfach mal Format.
Ich möchte mir also jetzt einen Rahmen anlegen,
um darin dann später meine technische Zeichnung anzulegen
und dafür kann ich natürlich die Zeichenfeder nehmen.
Aber es gibt auch einen viel schnelleren Weg,
nämlich mit der Rechteckfunktion.
Du siehst hier links unweit von der Zeichenfeder,
ein bisschen weiter unten ein Rechtecksymbol.
Da klickst du jetzt mal drauf.
Jetzt klickst du auf dein Platt Papier
Und
Hältst jetzt deine Maus oder deinen Trackpad gedrückt und
ziehst in eine Richtung und du wirst sehen,
es entsteht ein Rechteck.
Wenn jetzt gleichzeitig noch die Shift-Taste gedrückt hält,
entsteht ein Quadrat.
Ich möchte aber jetzt erstmal ein Rechteck haben,
also brauche ich die Shift-Taste nicht drücken und ziehe mir
jetzt dieses Rechteck über mein Platt Papier.
Das ist jetzt mein Rahmen.
In diesen Rahmen möchte ich jetzt noch einen Abschnitt
einfügen.
Dazu nehme ich das Linienwerkzeug,
das findet ihr hier in dieser Werkzeugleiste,
auch nicht weit vom Rechteck entfernt und da klickt ihr
jetzt mal drauf, dann geht ihr wieder auf eure
Zeichenfläche,
positioniert euch auf der einen Seite des Rechtecks.
Jetzt zieht ihr rüber auf die andere Seite und ihr seht,
es entsteht so eine Linie.
Haltet gedrückt, nicht loslassen und wenn ich jetzt die
Shift-Taste gedrückt halte,
dann kann ich eine ganz gerade Linie zeichnen.
Das heißt sie ist da nicht mehr in einem beliebigen Winkel.
Also ziehe ich jetzt meine ganz gerade Linie,
indem ich die Shift-Taste gedrückt halte,
bis zur anderen Seite von dem Rechteck und jetzt wenn ich
da gut positioniert bin,
lasse ich los und habe also meine gerade Linie gezeichnet.
Alternativ kann ich das natürlich auch mit der Zeichenfeder
machen.
Jetzt möchte ich in diesem Abschnitt noch einen Text
hinzufügen.
Dafür geht ihr in eurer Werkzeugleiste auf das T
wie Textwerkzeug und positioniert euch dann auf eurer
Zeichenfläche dort wo ihr den Text einfügen möchtet.
Du gehst jetzt also auf deine Zeichenfläche und kannst dir
hier direkt ein Textfeld definieren oder alternativ kannst
du einfach gleichlos schreiben.
Ich persönlich mag es immer,
wenn ich hier schon ein Feld vordefiniert habe.
Ja an dieser Stelle merkt ihr schon,
es gibt sehr viele verschiedene Arbeitsweisen mit Adobe
Illustrator.
Ich stelle meine Arbeitsweise vor,
versuche euch aber auch immer gleich ein paar Alternativen
zu nennen und ihr könnt dann für euch herausfinden,
was am besten passt.
So ich schreibe jetzt hier in mein Textfeld technische
Modezeichnung und dann mein Name.
Ihr könnt dort auch eure Firma oder euer Modelabel
eintragen.
Technische Zeichnung dient ja meist dazu,
sie dann an eine Produktionsfirma zu senden und deshalb ist
es dann immer gut einzutragen,
was zeichne ich jetzt und von wem ist diese Zeichnung.
Wir wollen als erstes eine technische Zeichnung von einem
Rock anfertigen.
Parallel dazu haben wir Kurse für die Schnittkonstruktion
und fertigen dort einen Modellrock an.
Also nenne ich meine technische Zeichnung Modellrock 1 und
füge noch meinen Namen hinzu.
Jetzt ist erstmal meine Grundformatierung fertig und ich
möchte diese Grundformatierung auch nicht weiter
verschieben.
Also sperre ich jetzt meine Ebene, drücke also
neben diesem Auge auf die Fläche,
es entscheint das Schlosssymbol und ich kann meine Ebene
jetzt nicht weiter bearbeiten.
Das hat den Vorteil, dass sie dann eben auch nicht
verrutschen kann.